[Music]
there was a competition some while ago a
company but how long ago the amongst
mathematicians they decided what what's
the minimum number of shapes that it
will record that a you can tile an
infinite floor with this is how they
amused themselves I think and at one
point and I will I know I'll get the
details wrong but I think it was a
Chinese chat had it down to several
thousand shapes with student write
several thousand shapes you could prove
that you could tile an infinite space
with these this set number of tiles and
the patent would never repeat so it's
not like a square tile and then Roger
got involved because he thought that
sounds interesting
would anyone like to guess how many
shapes roger has got it down to just
shout out and everyone else went all
right it worked its way down I think it
got down to about a hundred by Robert
burger who had the number actually and
then it got down to kept working its way
down to until it got down to six and I
was aware of that six I has another way
of doing it with six you see but when I
heard about that and I was told that the
chap who did this like to find the
smallest number so I said well I can do
it with five because I could glue two of
my bits together well it wasn't quite
like that but but then fiddling around
and there got it answer to and that was
the end of that competition but the
engine thing about it is you think well
that's interesting pastime but actually
this work on on a periodic tiling has
tremendous things to say about the
limits of logic and the way that
consciousness might work
and it's one of the things that's most
interesting like the work is that Roger
goes off on all these different
directions but are you all are you
thinking of this will give me another
Avenue back to this because they your
work has been tremendously varied but
but it does sort of double back to
things that you've always been
preoccupied like the limits of logic I
don't know whether I can answer that
question I don't know I just do what
interests me mainly and the logic thing
I had lots of conversations when I was
an undergraduate with Ian Percival we
used to talk about well a lot of other
things but logic was certainly one of
the things we talked about and I was
very worried by this thing called
girdle's theorem because it seemed to
show that there were things in
mathematics you couldn't prove and then
when I went to Cambridge as a graduate
student and I went to three lecture
courses which were nothing to do with my
actual work well most by Hermann Bondi
general relativity in cosmology one was
by Paul Dirac famous quantum mechanics
one of the founders of quantum mechanics
and he gave they were both beautiful
sets of lectures in a completely
different way and then I went to another
course which was a course by a man
called Steen on mathematical logic
because I was interested in this gödel
question and I learned about Turing
machines there's a general receipt well
the basis of modern computers if you
like Turing machines and I learned about
girl's theorem and I learnt it's my
relief because it was not that girl
showed that there are things you
couldn't prove it's just that if you had
a particular set of rules that you
follow and that these rules are things
you could put on a computer to check
whether they've done been done right
then
those rules you can find some other
example and these are improve things
about numbers you see and infinite
things
things about numbers such as for example
every number is the sum of four square
numbers it proved by LaGrone it's quite
a hard or that every even number greater
than 2 is the sum of two prime numbers
that's still improved things of that
sort you see these are statements about
the infinite now the question is you've
got certain rules about how you prove
things and if you fix those rules and if
you believe they only give you truths
what girdle does he comes along says
well look here's a statement of just the
same kind but you could see by virtue of
understanding what the statement means
that you cannot prove it using those
rules if you trust those rules to only
give you truths so if you're using the
rules only give you true things there's
another thing which you can see is true
by virtue of your knowledge that the
rules will and get even true things but
you cannot prove it using the rules I'm
if that's twist of logic there so you
can you you can tell it's true by
knowing that the rules only give you
truths but you can't use it prove it
using the rules yes I found that
stunning you see yes absolutely stunning
I mean in case that's puzzling that's
the deep mathematical version of this
statement is false yes you all
understood it because you understand the
rules of the English language but you
can't decide whether what I said is true
or not
yes it has to be that's not because I
didn't say properly or that you didn't
understand it properly and that's a
trivial version and really says this
statement is not provable by those rules
yes but proved it and and is it would
you agree that it basically made him the
most unpopular logician
ever well well I'd say that if you he
taught at the University of Vienna and
if you go to the courtyard the
university they're big huge building and
they have a very proudly a bust in in
marble every single famous professor or
any professor who taught there going
back several centuries
except for Kirk Godel
well that's a big mistake yes oh so no
he opened up all sorts of the Evald up
huge areas of mathematics no yes but he
does pull the rug out from under the
pretension yes you will have a formal
system yes which once you've got it you
will be able to give you the correct
answer to any question you give it which
is the still the founding belief that
we'll be able to create an AI and when
we do it'll give us the answer to
everything
yeah girls rather clearly said no it
won't wait um yeah that's where it leads
you
I mean it shows you that's the way it
led me you see yes but that's made you I
don't popular tune people disagree with
me let's actually do what they quit a
few quite a few bought my book the
Empress's popularity of it well no but I
just spent I spent several months
interviewing lots and lots of the the
techie boys who are and doing the AI
revolution and if I mention your name
they go you yes well that's you see it
does show that there is something
different going on in this well they
learnt from Steen's course it may not
have been quite how he put it but but
there is something going on in human
understanding which is not computational
it it's different from what a computer
does so okay when people call it
artificial intelligence I think that's a
misnomer
well cleverness perhaps right but they
see stands for an alternating current so
you couldn't say for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you